[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle valérie létard je
suis sénatrice du nord et je suis vice
présidente du sénat
[Musique]
la loi dont vous parlez en fait qui vise
à limiter l'usagé en fait du protoxyde
d'azoté le gaz hilarant qui aujourd'hui
est le troisième produit psychoactif
consommée par les jeunes en france et
qui est un produit qui n'est pas
considéré comme un stupéfiant qui est en
vente libre et que l'on peut consommer
qu'on soit d'ailleurs mineurs ou majeurs
j'ai été alertée très fortement par
l'association des maires du nord qui ont
été parmi les premiers territoires être
fortement impacté par la présence de ces
capsules qui traînait sur les bords des
routes en 2019 j'avais posé la question
d'actualité en fait au ministre en
charge qui considérait que c'est un
sujet qu'on pouvait par une petite
information une sensibilisation une
prévention circonvenir le sujet le coc
vide est passée par là et le phénomène a
explosé le ministère de la santé ne
l'avait pas identifié comme étant sévère
et c'est bien la remontée du terrain des
élus locaux qui l'ont constaté qu'ils ne
savaient plus comment faire qui était
désarmée face au phénomène qui nous a
amenés à aller plus loin et a proposé la
loi et c'est nous qui avons été un peu
les lanceurs d'alert et donc on voit
bien aussi l'intérêt est bien du travail
d'initiative parlementaire qu'on peut
porter
un
grand père qui était mère d'un tout
petit village rural bon j'ai grandi dans
ce village j'ai participé à des tas de
moments de rassemblements familiaux où
on parlait toujours de la chose publique
j'ai un père qui s'est engagé aussi en
politique peut-être pour les mêmes
raisons c'est une passion que de
s'intéresser à la vie publique
[Musique]
je suis entré en politique
par mon engagement territoriales tout
d'abord professionnels et puis une
rencontre avec un élu qui m'a marqué et
qui m'a proposé de passer de la vie
professionnelle à la vie politique cet
homme il s'appelle jean louis borloo en
fait dans les années 90 jean louis
borloo a été élu maire de valenciennes
est recruté une directrice de la
politique de la ville je me suis
présenté il m'a recruté et huit ans plus
tard il portait une liste aux élections
régionales
je me suis embarqué dans l'aventuré avec
lui ça a été mon premier mandat d'élu
régional
et puis ensuite en 2001 et bien le sénat
s'ouvrait à la parité et jean louis m'a
encouragé aussi à continuer l'aventuré à
me présenter dans le cadre d'un scrutin
de liste
[Musique]
j'ai toujours eu l'envi de défendre les
territoires qui étaient un peu oublié
des territoires périphériques comme la
ruralité tous ceux qui ont besoin aussi
du soutien de la république et des élus
de proximité et j'ai toujours pensé que
le sénat avait un intérêt celui de
défendre ces collectivités qui
permettent de faire en sorte que ce
qu'on décide au niveau national et bien
puisse être mise en oeuvre de la
meilleure façon possible et qu'on doit à
défendre ces territoires quand on défend
les collectivités on défend
l'application concrète de l'action que
l'on mène au niveau national
[Musique]
on dit toujours que que voilà que le
nord c'est la chaleur et et c'est vrai
qu'on a une tradition d'abord de
proximité de chaleur une attention
portée à la dimension humaine et c'est
lié aussi à notre à notre façon d'être
vient d'un territoire le valenciennois
qui a connu en dix ans la fin de la
sidérurgie et des mines l'a connu
successivement beaucoup de crise
beaucoup de difficultés et bien jamais
légende baisse les bras c'est plus une
façon d'être d'être solidaires et de
faire face à l'adversité je trouve qui
caractérise le nord les gens qui se
battent ils y arrivent toujours et quand
on est solidaires face à des difficultés
comme ça eh bien on s'en sort toujours
mais moi j avec 7 ce tempérament là
[Musique]